what's the big deal anyway so I'm
feeling good about myself oh so what
I'll tell you so what okay
you you you feeling good about yourself
and me feeling lousy that's not gonna
fly buddy so here's how it's gonna go
down okay you're gonna hang up your old
chain you're gonna let your nose hair
grow and we're gonna go back to sitting
on the couch and feeling just okay
because that's what marriage is Kevin
James and Leah Remini first joined
forces on the popular CBS comedy the
king of queens for nine seasons now
they've reunited for the second season
of Kevin can wait on CBS they play
former police partners Remini joined the
cast after successful guest appearances
in season one we asked them to interview
each other for our ongoing series
something in common there we go like
this one to the exactly human okay I'm
gonna do this so I'm like very
comfortable I'm doing the stretch up
move yeah the big guy
move are you good when you have a shirt
I don't know okay all right well so
we're gonna interview each other here on
something in common
I've never interviewed anybody before
Lee hi REM and I really know I would I'm
I'm glad to be your first Kevin thank
you do you have any questions for me oh
I do have a question for you
what when did you first catch the acting
bug as early as I can remember I mean I
grew up on television watching I Love
Lucy and I remember hearing the laughs
from the audience and I was like wow to
be able to do that but now I feel like
you're not listening I really might I'm
thinking my next question okay that's
not a good interface not good I'm not
good at this okay but yeah Kevin yes did
you answer that one by the way I did but
you didn't hear me no I did but the
people at home heard me so they anybody
who's married understands that you
didn't listen to a word I said I got the
gist what did I say Lucy
understand this I thrive in this
environment
[Music]
[Applause]
yep
do you remember the first laugh you got
on the stage my first laugh that i got
like i got it from a public speaking i
was doing a public speaking class I
picked that in college cuz I was a shy
kid you were yeah I was very shy I was
like shot no no that was just quiet so I
I took an easy class and someone said
it's public speaking it's easy it's an
easy grade you'll get it right away
never thinking I'd have to public speak
in the class right and then I found out
that was the final two public speak and
I got a laugh and how did it make you
feel it made me feel all grown up
no really Kevin it made me feel good
I gotta ask you a question okay good
this is very unprofessional yeah okay I
know as a kid it was your dream to be an
Emmy can you sing I cannot tomorrow
I can't the song tomorrow I can but I
mean I for us can you sing it for us
sure go ahead
oh god I said okay wait hey guys let me
get him like Gideon I'll be getting my
cake
let me give you some keys a little bit
[Music]
we're just gonna move on okay
that was a rough one yes yeah I'm doing
great okay good
look at you with your beard yeah that's
good right no when did you know you made
it I don't think anybody in this
business everything they really made it
right it's always for me it's always a
sense of they're gonna figure yeah yeah
like it's like I'm getting by I'm doing
things that I love what I do but I don't
know right you never know you never know
and and you have some success you just
don't have you don't have job security
this is not a job for somebody to go
I've made it right but you've done you
done great you know you've done great no
I mean last week we were fired up
[Laughter]
[Music]
finish the sentence secret I wish I had
never folded my leg and sat down because
it's my knee is gonna pop is a lot of
weight on the structural part of my knee
that I'm trying to look comfortable
right now uh-huh
knee fell asleep about three questions
in she's gonna be a B ox to get up it's
gonna be a tough one you can't eat
around the bite marks nation and you are
yapping about your burger um so Lee I
yes and if you wouldn't mind speaking to
the tiny microphone of my blouse that'd
be super I like
okay Leah yep is there something in this
career of yours that you have not yet
achieved that you would like to achieve
is there anything that you would like
never played Annie on Broadway it's a
circle of life really if you think about
it
yeah the subtle come out tomorrow bet
your bottom there'll be Sun dun dun dun
and just thinking about okay I won't do
it but the thing about these two I used
to watch them on King of Queens they
were playing a married couple and now
they're playing you know police officer
partners they are so good the two of
them they play off of each other so well
they have that thing called chemistry
very natural and a comic Tommy
yeah great together you can watch the
second season of Kevin can wait Mondays
at a new time starting tonight it airs
at 8:00 7:00 central
right here on CBS